final day of 2022
what's worth remembering
[Music]
yep it's end of the year time which
means I'll do a quick little overview of
how the year was for me on a number of
fronts and also talk about what I
thought the best pieces of entertainment
this year were this is a broad top 10.
it will contain shows it'll contain
movies that'll contain video games I'm
not doing separate categories for each
I'm just lumping them all together in a
top ten I don't watch enough of any one
category to do one well I could do one
of just movies but then I don't see
enough new shows to do a top 10 of those
maybe a top five be iffy and I've been
playing more games that are several
years old so that kind of gets weird I
like to just lump them all together in
one thing that said I'll have a fair
number of honorable mentions because
this has been a pretty strong year
especially when it came to movies in
some areas not all we'll get to that
I'll do some dishonorable mentions uh as
well but for me this has been
a bit of a tumultuous year there's a lot
of stuff going on in the world
particularly in terms of the open
hostility towards
queer people trans people and specific
that
I could really really do without
um so that's not that's not great
personal life has been a bit up and down
um I like I'm okay I'm doing okay but
previous years uh over the last two two
previous years of the pandemic I kind of
had years that are like yeah there's a
lot bad on the grand scale but like my
on a personal level they were pretty
good years not as much the case this
time but I got through it in terms of my
output my work what I do I hit all of my
uh growth goals for my various platforms
I wanted to get to 60 000 on this uh
Channel I did I wanted to break 10 000
on the break room of Geeks that happened
actually a ways back uh into the year I
wanted to break six thousand on the
Council of Geeks Twitter I did that
wanted to break 2 000 on the Vera wild
Twitter I did that
um I wanted to hit 50 000 on Tick Tock
which I just barely just barely under
the wire on that one and uh I did also
have certain number goals for the
spicy page that exists elsewhere and I
hit those as well and
so that all felt good
uh there were some things that I had
hoped to get done that I didn't I really
wanted to get the audiobook of my novel
dreams of fire finished and made
available this year that hasn't happened
it will happen next year I don't know
exactly when it is a long process doing
the editing on that it'll get done I
just I can't I can't say exactly when
um so you know some disappointment there
in terms of my output and of specific
things and videos
um my most successful videos were not
exactly what I would have preferred them
to be my three most successful videos
were videos about Ezra Miller JK Rowling
and Joss Whedon so
unfortunately even with plenty to talk
about with new announcements regarding
Doctor Who my most viewed stuff is
basically breakdowns of drama and
Scandal which
I I try and be selective about the ones
I choose to do and have them be ones
that I actually feel like I have
something to say but I don't super enjoy
doing them and I really don't like that
it's my most viewed stuff of the year
and my top three most viewed at that but
it happens and I kind of expected it
settings time most successful some of
the videos that I made this year that I
am particularly proud of include the
video that I did on disability
representation on depictions of consent
of the video I did about representation
of fat bodies framed around a
conversation about fat Thor I got to go
to Gallifrey one where I met Jason hey
Gallery I got to interview him I'm very
proud of that I'm quite proud of the
video I did on book Bannings and
challenges I'm quite proud of the MCU
body count series which launched this
year and will end next year I'm going to
finish out the core six Avengers as I
said I would but that'll be it the while
I am proud of those videos they don't do
especially well especially consider how
much work they are so that series will
not continue past uh finishing out the
six original Avengers so we have
remaining Hulk Black Widow and Thor but
then that'll be it next year the video
I'm most proud of actually is not a
council of Geeks video it's a video over
on the Vera wild Channel and it was a
video talking to content creators who
got into
[Music]
um more spicy Cree content creation
after first finding success in more
mainstream platforms and what that
Journey was like What drew them to that
and what that experience was like I
basically made a documentary it's it's
about 85 minutes long I'm really proud
of that didn't get a ton of views
um but I'm really really happy with how
that turned out but that's enough of a
look at me myself personally let's talk
about the pieces of entertainment from
this year there was a lot good there was
a lot of good stuff that did not make
this list officially include things like
our flag means death wakanda forever
Umbrella Academy Season three the
Hellraiser reboot was surprisingly good
I actually would count power of the
doctor I was shocked at how much I liked
that and I've rewatched it I still liked
it a lot that was real fun to to
discover that it wasn't just the uh spur
of the moment that I was liking it in I
am that one person on the internet who
defends Thor love and thunder I had a
lot of fun with it violent night was
great we had two seasons of dead end
paranormal Park this year which were
both great my father's dragon we're the
Al Yankovic story was a delight
Shredder's revenge was a video game
released this year that was a perfect
blend of nostalgic entertainment really
bringing to mind the old TMNT beat em
ups from the Konami era while being more
up to date and more modern that was a
great time Barbarian has an impeccable
First Act it didn't fully lose me but it
doesn't hold me as well once it gets
past that but that First Act of that
movie is
absolute gold no notes and the one that
came the closest to making the list
proper it like by that much it missed it
was Star Trek strange new worlds that
one was real close that's real good I'm
looking forward to hopefully following
it as it is released in the new year
those are the honorable mentions there
were also a few things that I had really
wanted to get to and I will hopefully
get to in the new year and do reviews
when I do but I did not manage to fit
them in before the year ended so they
are not considering in consideration for
this list
so some things that I really wanted to
get to and see this year that I just
haven't had the time for include
Guillermo del Toros Pinocchio top gun
Maverick prey Wednesday and the new
Interview with a Vampire series I would
like to check out all these I'm hopeful
that I'll enjoy all of them I have not
had the time to get to them we're gonna
hold off on the dishonorable mentions
until we start to do some of the list
proper I'll come back to those but let
us do the top 10 pieces of entertainment
according to me
in 2022
number 10.
A League of Their Own
so you may have caught that our flag
means death got an honorable mention I
did enjoy our flag means death I
appreciated what it was doing but it
wasn't quite fully clicking with me
this did
this was basically my super queer show
of the Year this show is really really
gay
and really sweet and wonderful and
focusing on the bonds and the
relationships between these women and
being reflective of the major part of
the story of this era of women's
baseball women's sports this stretch of
time that the movie which I love it's
one of the only Sports movies I own
that movie wasn't really allowed to deal
with either issues of sexuality or of
race it touched on them incredibly
briefly in the movie and they are front
center here issues of race get full
exploration issues of sexuality get full
exploration and it delivers all of that
fantastically with great characters that
I really came to love and I hope we get
more
number
vampire survivors so this is the one
video game that is on the list this is
kind of the um the little game that
could it's uh fairly simple on at least
in theory a game that is it's a little
bit of an endless game it's kind of a
horrid game there games like this have
existed for a little bit but usually as
money grubbing heavily monetized free to
play games on mobile this I have played
on PC it is very cheap to just buy
there's no monetization in it other than
some recent DLC which is really good DLC
by the way I have now unlocked almost
everything there is to unlock in that
DLC that's also fantastic new characters
to play as the new map is great and it's
just so I saw somebody in the comments
when I reviewed it in the break room of
Geeks which most of these have been
reviewed in the break room of geek so
you should be subscribed there if you
aren't already
um described it as a bullet Heaven game
as opposed to a bullet hell and I that
really is a good descriptor it is just
so rewarding to play to get more
powerful to unlock things you are
unlocking things constantly it is so
rewarding and it really it hits the same
receptors that so many deeply predatory
games aim for
but without preying on you for extra
money
oh it's so fun
number eight
the Batman a movie that I was convinced
I was not gonna like I was so exhausted
of dark and broody Batman I thought
there's no way I'm going to enjoy this
I'm just so done with this even if it's
good I'm not gonna like it but you know
what
it was good and I really like it the
funny thing is if I were to take
individual components
I'm not sure that any of them are my
favorite anything this isn't my favorite
Batman
I don't think this is my favorite Alfred
this is not my favorite Commissioner
Gordon
I don't think this is my favorite
Catwoman I do this is definitely not my
favorite Riddler but they are exactly
the right versions of each of these
characters for this movie this setting
this tone in this story
they don't have to be the best in the
bat in a vacuum because they were the
right ones for this iteration
it's just something that I mean saying
something is more than the sum of his
Parts is a bit of a cliche but it really
is it really is it takes component parts
that individually I didn't have a lot of
interest in
but it's using them because they fit so
well together
it is a three-hour movie that does not
feel like it's that long it is so well
focused it it truly brought in the Noir
and the detective sense which was
something that they had said they were
going to do but I didn't believe them
but they they actually did it
and I'm genuinely excited for more of
this iteration of Batman and I have not
been able to say that about any
adaptation of Batman in a while
number seven
the Sandman now this one is placement is
a little bit weird it's certainly not
better than the original and I do deeply
love the original
and part of my love of this is as an
adaptation when I did a video on this it
wasn't straight up a review it was to
talk about how intelligently adapted it
was because knowing the original as well
as I know it and seeing what they took
on board what they tweaked and noticing
okay
for the reason I think that they did
that that's a really smart change
the adaptations were so smart and it
preserved pretty much everything that
you would want preserved about Sandman
while tweaking things that weren't
necessarily flaws in the original but
now work better for the way it's being
presented that was a smart change and
those are across the board all over the
place it it is just good flat out but I
experienced it as an adaptation and it
is a masterful adaptation
number six
Glass Onion
just barely squeaked in towards the end
of the year I was fairly confident I was
gonna like this but I also thought in
the back of my head it's not going to be
as good as knives out and the one thing
that it can't recreate is the newness of
knives out and it can't catch me off
guard in quite the same way to quite the
same degree
but you know what it is as good
it is actually just as good as Knives
Out
and that was such a delight to watch it
it's an amazing cast that is funny it is
a terrific skewing of a very different
kind of rich person from the folks who
got skewered and knives out which was
also great partly for that reason as
well but this is
and especially in light of some things
that have gone on
um in the last month or two uh with some
of the people that are the type of
person that this is sending up it just
makes it all the more fun this is great
number five
Peacemaker
when I knew that James gone was doing a
spin-off from The Suicide Squad and I
heard it was going to be Peacemaker I
remember thinking why
what is there to do with a character
like this
a lot as it turns out
because James Gunn is proving himself to
be a specialist in the examination and
the deconstruction of toxic masculinity
and if you're gonna do that
Peacemaker is not only a good character
he is in fact the perfect character to
do that with to really examine what
makes someone who has some moral
grounding who has some desire to help
and do good but just has a deeply messed
up sense of who he is supposed to be and
to understand where that comes from and
how even though he's trying to make
himself better he's still hampered in a
lot of ways and might always be
acknowledging the limitations of his
ability to be a better person while
putting so much emphasis on the fact
that he is trying to the best of his
ability it's really really well balanced
and the rest of the cast is great it's a
terrific ensemble cast and one of the
best opening credit sequences in
television history don't even try and
argue with me on that
number four
Andor
oh did a fairly recent video on this but
it has been a long time
since I have liked
something Star Wars this much
this captures an aspect of Star Wars
that I feel is underexplored is
underappreciated
the life and the turmoils of day-to-day
people under the heel of the empire
this gives them voice this gives them
Focus this emphasizes that the need to
defeat the Empire is because of the
lives of these people
normal people
whose names will never be remembered
never recorded by history they matter
and when they stand up as one and they
fight because you have to this is such a
brilliant piece of anti-fascist
entertainment
you don't fight because you yourself are
imminently threatened you fight because
someone everyone who can has to fight
this thing however they are able
it was so rewarding it was so well paced
it was so well acted it was so perfectly
focused it was lacking any of the fan
service stuff that feels like it's just
there to make people go oh I recognize
the thing like none of that it was so
just determined to be the best version
of what it was and it succeeded
so before we get to the top three
we are going to cover some dishonorable
mentions broadly speaking the MCU was a
bit of a letdown this year there were a
couple that made my honorable mention
like wakanda forever and Thor love and
thunder but you know they also weren't
enough to make the top ten and I still
like the MCU but there were also some
fairly big disappointments uh She-Hulk
is getting a partial dishonorable
mention it did thankfully pull together
in the last three episodes which are
great and if they do another season I
hope that they build off what those did
much more than what the first chunk of
it was because it really felt like it
floundered for a bit but those last
three episodes were really good and
really focused and really smart and I
want more of that
it took a while to get there though I
was really worried I wasn't gonna like
any of it because I not only do I love
She-Hulk as a character I love the
specific stories that this show was
pulling its influences from so not
liking as much of that show as I did was
already a disappointment it did
thankfully pull it together at the end
the Marvel piece that is getting a full
dishonorable mention though because it
is the single most
disappointing piece of entertainment
that I took in all year
is Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness it was okay when I watched it
originally
but the more I've thought about it
the less there is to like there was some
fun ideas some neat visuals I
appreciated Sam raimi's visual Flair
like pretty much everything that I like
about it I can pretty much chalk up to
that the writing is
eh it's uninventive given the premise
given the title it's quite uninventive
and it really did want to dirty just as
a character it did her dirty really
badly
and I was kind of like oh that's a shame
after I first thought but the more I
think about it like that's no
no it's actually really messed up all
the best stuff was thanks to raymie and
the Flair and energy that he brought and
that's what kept it from being any kind
of worse that's why I say it's the most
disappointing movie it's not the worst
movie this year I don't really see I go
out of my way to avoid movies that I
think I will really dislike
so I don't really have a worst
but I do have a most disappointing
and yeah that was an easy shoe-in
but let's get back to the good stuff top
three
number three
nope
oh Jordan peel
ah he hasn't let me down yet
get out was phenomenal us is a movie
that gets better every time I re-watch
it and nope is not a letdown from that
Legacy
it is
so tense and so visually inventive in
terms of not only the way it is shot but
the the depiction and the design of some
of the stuff that goes on is
horrifyingly gorgeous
the performances across the board just
they suck you in they make you care
about these characters that make you
want them to be okay and it is so tense
waiting to see what is going to happen
and it's it does some things that I had
to like sit with and really think about
why is that there what does it mean and
realizing oh that's why oh it's even
better than I thought like first coming
out of it I already liked it but it's
one of those movies you know how I kind
of said that the more I thought about
Doctor Strange of the Multiverse of
Madness the less I liked it the more I
think about this movie the more I like
it
it's oh gosh it's so good
number two
r r r
this is easily the most cathartic and
joyous experience that I had watching
this year
I did I did a full review on that I I
think I'm pretty sure I did full reviews
for everything I'm talking about it
the sense of just jumping up from my
seat and pumping my fist in the air and
going yes while watching this which I
did actually literally do while watching
it alone in my freaking living room it's
just so triumphant this movie The
Presence of the leads their chemistry
this is the greatest Bromance put to
film since Hot Fuzz it's phenomenal the
action is ridiculous in the best way
don't bother asking how physics Works
physics is taking the day off this is
Rule of cool we allow it cause it's
awesome and we need no more
justification than that but even aside
from that like a movie cranked up to 11
like this should wear you down it
doesn't because it shifts its focus
everything is cranked up to 11 but we're
gonna do
action scene cranked up to 11. romance
scene cranked up to 11. phenomenal dance
scene cranked up to 11. it shifts its
focus enough and even like doing
melodrama cranked up to 11 it's hitting
different emotional notes as it goes so
you're still getting that that reprieve
so you're not like getting action
overload but everything is still so
heightened it's
so good
it ah
it came close to getting the number one
it's real close
that
I I do have to acknowledge there is a
propagandist aspect to it like
especially towards the very end
I will acknowledge that that does not
diminish my opinion and I will still
happily keep watching this and
re-watching it
but there is that but also
as amazing as this is
the creativity that went into the number
one
singles out of something truly deeply
special
my pick for the number one everything
everywhere all at once
how much was Marvel kicking itself in
the head when this came out and they
realized oh my gosh
people people have seen what you can
actually do with the concept of a
Multiverse and we did this lame ass
thing
this
is what you can do with a truly
inventive approach rather than using a
concept to tell a fairly standard story
that could have been told with any other
number of Concepts this takes a concept
like a Multiverse and tells a story that
truly could not be told by any mechanism
other than a Multiverse
and it's not just about dealing with
alternate versions of yourself
everything about how everything is
interconnected is intercut is interwoven
this story should be impossible to
follow it's not because it centers on
characters and it makes you care about
those characters all of them
phenomenally acted every single one
Michelle yo first of all huh
but also Stephanie Sue Jamie Lee Curtis
K Yukon oh my gosh this this cast the
action scenes are amazing and
Preposterous and the build of this
hooking this core emotional story Making
It ultimately a story that is
emotionally quite simple even as the
logistics are mind-bending
this is a story that I do not think
could have been told in any way other
than the way they told it and it is a
unique
just Masterpiece this is
art
I'm not even sure I could call it an
artsy film
but it is undoubtedly art
it does something that I've not seen
done before
narratively visually
this is a unique piece that deserves all
the celebration
and I think it was the best thing that I
saw this year
that is 2022 my friends what did you
think was the best stuff that came out
this year anything
books I didn't even talk about because I
I didn't read anything that was new this
year but books video games shows movies
what did you think was the best stuff
drop something down in the comments let
us talk about it patreon's what pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living even if you can't support me that
way like share subscribe help me out
links in the description to other things
that I do other ways you can follow or
support me
but what I really want you to remember
especially going into a new year
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just privileged
enough to get to run the meetings
and until next time
next year
this council is adjourned
[Music]
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin mcfula
Tarak the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjornison Melinda
Walters kimudelki the oatha Boyd katoria
toileoli Becky Sparks for nabilax the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what are you doing there
[Music]